what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from nor McDonald and Shane
Gillis Louie Chappelle norm and then
it's Bernie Macker Patrice to Joe Rogan
and Richard prior did you ever meet
Richard I actually worked with Richard
for 5 weeks in a row these are your
favorite comedian's biggest Inspirations
starting off with the man who's brought
more eyeballs to the world of standup
comedy than anyone in recent history Joe
Rogan has skyrocketed the popular
popularity of this art form while
transforming the careers of countless
Comics but the podcast King's first real
exposure to standup came when he was
just 15 years old when his mom took him
to see Richard prior live on the Sunset
Strip an experience that had a profound
impact on young Joe Rogan from that day
forward he was a reason why I even
understood what comedy was when I was 15
years old my parents took me to see live
on the Sunset Strip in the movie theater
and I'll never forget cuz I had seen a
bunch of great movies like stripes and
you know all these funny funny funny
movies I had never laughed so hard as I
was laughing at this guy who just
talking and I couldn't imagine that this
was like how is this happening so I'm
sitting in the audience and I remember
looking around while I was laughing and
people are falling out of their chairs
they're throwing their arms up in the
air they they couldn't breathe and I was
like this is amazing all this guy's
doing is talking and that planted the
seed in my mind about what standup
comedy is Richard PRI inspired more than
one of the comedian in today's video so
be sure to stick around till the end if
you want to hear the entire list because
up next is Chris Rock whose biggest
comedic inspiration came from Bill Cosby
the concept of being inspired by Bill
Cosby might sound wild to people
nowadays but before becoming a
mixologist Bill Cosby used to be one of
the biggest names in comedy period and
was a major influence on Chris Rock who
claims Bill Cosby as the greatest of all
time and even says that his work is of
such high caliber that no one even
attempts to copy it none of Bill Cosby's
material is predicated on a reference
point every joke is so good yeah that it
withstands the reference and almost all
of them would work today yes because the
same way and you can't say that about
any other comedian that's so interesting
Bill Cosby played a role in inspiring
another all-time great comedian Jerry
Seinfeld who claims that it was seeing
people like Cosby and George Carlin on
television telling jokes as a job that
made young Jerry obsessed with the craft
once I knew I had some ability
I did not care if my life was going to
be a
absolutely minimal handt mouth existence
of just barely barely getting by I
didn't care I go I I want to be in this
life and this is really the key aspect
of a comedian is that you want to be
this and you don't care about anything
else Jerry Seinfeld not only went on to
become the first comedy billionaire ever
but also also inspired thousands of
young Comics through his standup and
sitcom including one of the best joke
writers alive today Mark Norman I was
doing him when I started and it was
embarrassing did you do a guy in the
beginning yeah I did Jenny okay I caught
myself on stage once going oh yes dude I
did sounds exactly like them I did an
open mic in New York and in New York
they were ruthless and uh I went on I
was walking to the mic and some kid in
the back
went and it crushed me speaking of Mark
Norman Kevin Hart used his booming
standup career to become one of the
biggest movie stars in the
world but it's possible that none of
this would have ever happened without
the influence of Eddie Murphy me and
Eddie Murphy talked I'm like Eddie
you're large reason why I'm doing
standup comic it's never a white guy but
be that as it may what I said dice was
the reason I I started because of dice
you know you're a living legend when
multiple people at the top of their game
site you as as their biggest inspiration
which is definitely the case with Eddie
Murphy and Chris Rock who both played a
massive influence in the career of Tom
sagora I think I'm at my funniest as a
standup on stage when I go on stage in a
silly mood silly for me is the is the
best way it's like you you loosen up
your Rolex and go it's so
loose I just feel like where am my poris
there's
there's I just feel like silly is fun
like playful yeah and like it's it's the
best way for me to go on stage and I
forget and the person that reminds me of
that is actually Eddie Murphy because
Eddie Murphy when he was like 21 doing
stand up there was a silliness with
which he went on stage and so I try to
remind myself of that like I'll just
look at a photo of him just like I'm
saying he was so masterful but there's
like a that silliness is what I I
aspired to to be like widely considered
one of the best comedians working today
Shane Gillis had a plethora of comedic
Inspirations throughout the years such
as Chappelle Burr and Patrice but by far
the two biggest influences on the Shane
Gillis we all know today were Louis CK
and nor McDonald when people were going
through it Norm was one of the guys that
would always reach out yeah that was it
just reached out he sent me some cool
stuff about like funny will win yeah
that was the coolest ever it was
like there's a war right I don't want to
I don't want to spill the beans on a
nice thing but it was like you guys had
a private thing yeah it was cool end
suppor he spoke like poetically it was
awesome and it ended one of the messages
with like in a war for comedy I think
the ones with jokes will win just like
yo that's fire nor McDonald is King yeah
and he in no way has to do that no you
know what I mean to reach out you know
especially at that time I thought was
really cool it was two years ago I mean
he yeah as he's battling something no
disrespect way worse yeah yeah yeah as
we've seen thus far most comedy greats
were inspired by the legends of the
previous generation and Bill Burr was no
different before we hear Bill Burr's
biggest comedy inspiration we got to
take a quick break to to hear from the
sponsor of today's video my bookie it's
the best time of year when it comes to
sports and my bookie is the best way to
get in on the fun especially if you take
advantage of their 100% firsttime
deposit match which basically means
whatever amount of money you put into
bet with the first time my bookie will
give you the same amount for free only
when you use our promo code JK wrld D my
bookie also has a super easy cash out
system odd boosting crypto payments and
the possibility to watch live games on
their website while you bet my favorite
play this weekend is over 51 in the
Eagles Dolphins game but let me hear
your favorite picks in the comments
again use promo code jkw rld to claim
your 100% cash bonus now back to the
video Burr once said that he was
inspired to pursue stand-up comedy after
watching Robin Williams perform on The
Tonight Show and that watching Robin's
performance gave him the courage to take
the risk of entering the world of
stand-up comedy aside from both being
angry gingers Andrew Santino has another
thing in common with Bill Burr they were
both inspired to pursue comedy in the
first place by comedians who were
masters of improv and acting you know
when I was a kid I spoke about this on
the other day when I was a kid working
with Jim on camera Carrie would have
been like the greatest thing he was my
boss for this show I did called I'm
dying up here that's right but which was
great that was always my dream thank you
dude that was my dream to like still to
this day would be the killer to work on
camera with that guy I don't think it'll
ever happen now because of the
circumstances because I don't know how
often he'll come back on camera but uh I
think he will I mean he still seems to
you know I think it's all you know Hey
listen Something Beautiful is written
yeah that's that's where the Hope turns
Poss I think he would come back if given
the perfect project so far we've taken a
look at who's inspired the careers of
some of the biggest comedy Legends ever
from Chris Rock to Jerry Seinfeld but
what comedians are inspiring the next
generation of household names I was a
huge fan of Dane Cook and Dave Chappelle
when I was like 12 134 and my mom won
tickets on the radio to see danne at
Nationwide Arena in Columbus it was like
nose bleed seats obviously but I was
just like so in all of the show it went
it was incredible and since that moment
I was like obsessed with it so then
couple weeks go by there's a talent show
at school I'm like I want to try it so I
do it there and of course it was
terrible but you got balls D but oh I
mean it was awful dude I was doing all
these runchy jokes that I had gotten off
the internet in front of my classmates
it's ballsy though it was so I was so
naive it's not you don't think of it as
Brave when you don't know that there
could be consequences true true and then
when I was 15 I I found out what an open
mic was and I just emailed the Columbus
Funny Bone Stroop and uh I was like hey
I know you have to be 21 and up but like
I really want to try what an open mic is
like could I come if I had like my
parents with me or something and he
happened to say yes and ever since then
it's just been comedy every single
week joke
world that's did it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out